so where we left off we had this
two-dimensional vector field V and I
have it pictured here as kind of a
yellow vector field and I just stuck it
in three dimensions in kind of an
awkward way where I put it on the XY
plane and said pretend this is in three
dimensions and then when you describe
the rotation around each point while we
were familiar with his 2d curl that's
where you get this this vector field
it's not quite a 3d vector field because
you're only assigning points on the XY
plane to three-dimensional vectors
rather than every point in space to a
vector but we're getting there so here
let's actually extend this to a fully
three-dimensional vector field and first
of all let me just kind of clear up the
board from the computations that we did
in the last compartment part and as I do
that kind of start thinking about how
you might want to extend the vector
field that I have here that's pretty
much two-dimensional into three
dimensions and one idea you might have
it's all kind of get rid of the circles
and the plane is to take this vector
field and then just kind of copy it into
different slices so you might get
something kind of like this and then I
draw I've run each slice a little bit
sparser than the original one so
technically that original one if you
look on the XY plane I've pictured many
more vectors but it's really the same
vector field and all I've done here is
set at every slice in space just copy
that same vector field so if you look
from above you can maybe see how really
it's just the same vector field kind of
copied a bunch and you if you look at it
each slice you know in the same way that
on the XY plane you've got this vector
field sitting on a slice every other
part of space will have that and even
though there's only what like six or
seven slices displayed here in principle
you're thinking that every one of those
infinitely many slices of space has a
copy of this vector field and in a
formula what does that mean well what it
means is we're taking not just x and y
as input points but we're going to start
taking Z in as well so if I go I'm going
to say that Z is an input point as well
and I want to be considering these as
vectors in three dimensions so rather
than just saying that it's got x and y
components I'm going to pretend like it
has a Z component it has a Z component
that just happens to be zero for this
case and the fact that you have a Z in
the input but the output doesn't depend
Z corresponds to the fact that all the
slices are the same as you change the Z
Direction the vectors won't change at
all they're just carbon copies of each
other and the fact that this output has
a Z component but it just happens to be
zero is what corresponds to the fact
that it's very flat looking you know
none of them point up or down in the Z
Direction they're all purely X&Y so as
three-dimensional vector fields go this
one is only barely a three-dimensional
vector field it's kind of phoning it in
as far as three-dimensional vector
fields are concerned but it'll be quite
good for our example here because now if
we start thinking of this as
representing a three dimensional fluid
flow so now rather than just kind of the
fluid flow like the one I have pictured
over here where you've got you know
water molecules moving in two dimensions
and it's very easy to understand
you know clockwise rotation
counterclockwise and things like that
whereas over here it's a very kind of
chaotic three-dimensional fluid flow but
because it's so flat if you view it from
above it's still loosely the same just
kind of counter clockwise over here on
the right and clockwise up there above
so if I were to draw like a column you
could think of this column as being
having a tornado of fluid flow right
where it's everything is kind of
rotating together in that same direction
so if you were to assign a vector to
each point in space to describe the kind
of rotation happening around each one of
those points in space you would expect
that those inside this column inside
this sort of counter clockwise is
rotating tornado and I say counter
clockwise but if we viewed it from below
it would look clockwise so that's the
tricky part about three dimensions and
why we need to describe it with vectors
but you would expect these using your
right hand rule where you curl the
fingers of your right hand around the
direction of rotation here you would
expect vectors that point up in the Z
direction the positive Z direction and
if I do that if I show what all of the
rotation vectors look like you'll get
this and maybe this is kind of a mess
because there's a lot of things on the
screen at this point so I'll get out for
the moment all I'll kind of remove that
original vector field and remove the XY
plane and just kind of focus on this new
vector field that I have pictured here
inside that column where we had that
that tornado of rotation I was
describing all of the vectors point in
the positive z direction but if we were
to if we were to view it elsewhere like
over in this region those are pointing
in the negative Z direction and if you
stick your thumb in the direction of all
of these vectors in the negative Z
direction
that tells you the direction of that
tells you how the fluid maybe you're
thinking about as air kind of rushing
about the room how that fluid rotates in
three dimensions
so what curl is gonna do here I'll kind
of clear things up I have the formula
from last time that hopefully hasn't
looked too in the way while I've been
doing this the described curl for a
2-dimensional vector field if we imagine
this not just taking X&Y as its inputs
because it's a three-dimensional vector
field but if we imagine it taking x y
and z so it's a proper three-dimensional
vector field the output is going to tell
you at every point in space what the
rotation the corresponds to that point
is and in the next video I'm gonna give
you give you the formula and tell you
how you actually compute this curl given
an arbitrary function but for right now
we're just getting the visual intuition
we're just trying to understand what it
is that curls going to represent and in
this vector field this one that was just
kind of copies of a 2d one put above
it's almost contrived because all of the
rotation happens in these perfect
perfect tornado like patterns that
doesn't really change as you move move
up and down in the X Y direction but
more generally you might have a more
complicated looking vector field so I'll
go ahead and kind of finally erase this
since it's been a little bit in the way
for a while and erase this guy too and
if you think about just arbitrary
three-dimensional vector fields like
let's say this one that I have here so I
don't know about you but for me it's
really hard to think about the fluid
flow associated with this I have a vague
notion in my mind that okay like fluid
is flowing out from this corner and kind
of flowing in here but it's very hard to
think about it all at once and certainly
if you start talking about rotation it's
hard to look at a given point say oh
yeah there's going to be a general fluid
rotation in some certain way and I can
give you the vector for that but as a
more loose and vague idea I can say okay
given that there's some kind of crazy
air current fluid flow happening around
here I can maybe understand that at a
specific point you're going to have some
kind of rotation and here I'll picture
it as if there's like a ball or a globe
sitting there in space and maybe you're
imagine you're your new vector field and
saying what kind of rotation is it going
to induce in that bulb it's just
floating there in space so maybe you're
imagining this as like a tennis ball
that you're sort of holding in place in
space using magnets or magic or
something like
and you're letting the wind sort of
freely rotate it and you're wondering
what direction it tends to rotate and
then when it does and once you have this
rotation you can describe that 3d
rotation with some kind of vector and in
this case it would be a vector that
points out in that direction because
we're kind of curling our fingers
curling our right hand fingers over in
that direction and if you don't
understand how we describe 3d rotation
with a vector I have a video on that
maybe go back and check out that video
but the idea here is that when you have
some sort of crazy fluid flow that's
induced by some sort of vector field and
you do this at every point and say hey
what's the rotation at every single
point that's gonna give you the curl
that is what the curl of a 3-dimensional
vector field is trying to represent and
if this feels confusing if this feels
like something that's hard to wrap your
mind around don't worry we've all been
there 3d curl is one of the most
complicated things in multivariable
calculus that we have to describe but I
think the key to understanding it is to
just kind of patiently think through and
take the time to think about what to
decal is and start thinking about how
you extend that to three dimensions and
slowly say okay okay I kind of get it in
tornadoes of rotation that sort of makes
sense and if you understand how to
represent three-dimensional rotation
around a single point with a vector then
understanding three-dimensional curl
comes down to thinking about doing that
at every single point in space according
to whatever rotation the wind flow
around that point would induce but like
I said it is complicated and it's okay
if it doesn't sink the first time it
certainly took me a while to really wrap
my head around this 3d curl idea and
with that I'll see you next video